1995 christian et marie-france des
pallières un couple qui a décidé de se
lancer dans une aventure assez peu
commune elle vient en aide à ces enfants
qui travaillent jour et nuit dans des
décharges au cambodge le couple sera
présent à versailles pour la projection
du film sur leur histoire le 22 avril
bonsoir dont patrice dufour responsable
local de l'association c'est avant tout
une histoire très touchante
comment vous l'avez découvert cette
histoire c'est une histoire
effectivement très touchante et c'est à
l'occasion d'une d'une mission au
cambodge qui m'a conduit dans le pays
pendant deux ans où je travaillais avec
l'administration cambodgienne que mon
épouse et moi avons eu le plaisir de
rencontrer christian et marie-france
despallières est ce qu'ils ont fait nous
a profondément ému et depuis on n'a pas
pu s'empêcher de continuer à oeuvrer
pour l'association parce que ce qu'ils
font est absolument formidable
leur combat a débuté en 95 96 1 +96
exactement oui ils ont accompli quoi
depuis écouter au début ils ont commencé
par voir ses enfants qui étaient sur la
décharge à trier les ordures à partir de
l'âge de trois ou quatre ans et ils se
sont dit bon ses enfants il faut les
nourrir parce que il se nourrissait de
la décharge avec de la nourriture qui
n'était pas celle dont il était tout le
temps malade affaibli et c'est donc ils
ont organisé un petit accueil pour les
nourrir et un peu à la fois ils se sont
rendus compte que les besoins ne
s'arrêtait pas là il fallait leur donner
des bottes pour qu'il puisse marcher
dans les ordures sans se couper les
pieds
et puis il fallait qu'ils puissent se
nettoyer se reposer et donc
progressivement on est arrivé au besoin
le plus important qui était celui d'une
éducation de renvoyer de permettre à ces
enfants d'aller à l'école et c'est là où
le programme vraiment commencé avec une
scolarisation qui aujourd'hui touchent
6500 enfants et ses enfants donc comme
ils n'ont pas été scolarisés vivent dans
des classes de rattrapage qui leur
permet de faire deux années à la place
d'une est d'arriver jusqu'à la fin de
leurs études avec d'excellents résultats
nourritures riches
scolarisation tous les domaines sont
concernés tout est à reconstruire là bas
et tout est à reconstruire parce que le
pays avait été dévastée vous vous en
souviendrez peut-être par l'épisode mer
rouge qui a quand même été un véritable
génocide puisque la moitié quasiment de
la population a été ou annihiler ou bien
déplacé et donc quand en 79 les khmers
rouges ont perdu le pouvoir au profit
des vietnamiens qui étaient venus
libérer entre guillemets le pays et
l'occupé par la même occasion
et bien tout était à refaire puisque les
élites avaient été décimées et il n'y
avait plus de culture il n'y avait plus
de racines et toutes les familles
avaient été affectés par cet épisode
dramatique et donc les enfants subissent
aujourd'hui le contrecoup de ce qu'ont
été leurs parents les parents ont été de
jeunes khmers rouges à qui on a appris à
mentir à qui on a appris à dénoncer à
qui on a appris à tuer et donc il y a un
fond de violence qui reste dans la
société notamment chez les plus pauvres
et c'est en grande partie pour protéger
les enfants de la violence familiale que
pour un sourire d'enfant opère mais pour
un sourire d'enfant quand le travail est
mené sur le terrain même au tout début
même si maintenant cela fait plusieurs
années
quel accueil a été réservé à ce couple
qui s'est investie à l'association qui
ensuite est né et qui a permis à
d'autres bénévoles de s'engager à
l'accueil a été formidable d'abord la
population les allées ça les accueillent
à bras ouverts les enfants les appels
papis et mamies et non pas et non pas
monsieur et madame et c'est
véritablement une famille et le pays
lui-même a marqué sa reconnaissance
puisque aussi bien christian que marie
france ont obtenu la nationalité khmer
et ils font partie maintenant de tous
ces gens qui essayent d'aider le pays à
s'en sortir
christian et marie-france des pallières
le couple qui a donc fondé cette
association qui sera présent le 22 avril
à 20h30 à l'université interâges à
versailles pour la projection du film
documentaire qui leur est consacrée qui
permet d'en savoir plus sur le travail
qui est mené on vous invite bien sûr à
vous y rendre voici un court extrait de
ce documentaire
c'est notre découverte en avant 1995 de
la décharge de plombs pen qui avait
provoqué la création de l'association là
dans un décor horrible une led pouvant à
une chaleur étouffante
au milieu des mouches et des rats des
centaines d'enfants pieds nus voyez un
espèce de bouillie décomposer plein
devait dans laquelle on enfoncé
jusqu'aux mollets il fallait voir leur
allure leur crasse avère maigreur
les plaies purulentes linguère épuisé et
puis le pire vous apercevez des enfants
qui ne mangeaient dans cette infection
c'est horrible à voir ou rester là comme
paralysés ne pensez pas que ça pouvait
exister
cela donnait envie de pleurer de vomir
et puis comme une rage la certitude
profonde qu'on ne pouvait pas laisser
des enfants dans ces conditions vous
devez pas les baisser qu'à partir de ce
moment notre vie allait changer pour un
sourire d'enfant c'est le nom de
l'association qui est né de ce constat
qui a été fait vous l'avez entendu vous
l'avez vu son des images assez assez
difficile en devoirs des enfants sortent
d'en vivre une telle ou telle situation
où les pouvoirs publics aujourd'hui vous
aide également les pouvoirs publics pas
directement c'est à dire que pour un
sourire d'enfant est financée
essentiellement par des dons privés ce
qui lui donne une très grande
indépendance est par contre il ya des
partenariats avec le gouvernement
notamment pour introduire dans les
écoles du cambodge les méthodes qui ont
permis de faire ce rattrapage scolaire
et aussi il y a un rôle de pionnier en
matière de formation professionnelle qui
est jouée par l'association dans la
mesure où les écoles professionnelles de
ps sont reconnus dans le pays comme
étant de très grande qualité et donc les
enfants qui en sortent trouve facilement
du travail
on est maintenant y'a plus de 2500
enfants qui sont sortis ce que je lis
près de 3000 qui sont sortis de deux de
ses écoles et qui obtiennent donc à se
placer dans l'association et eux mêmes
contribué à aider les générations
suivantes en parrainant d'autres enfants
parce que ils se sont rendu compte
qu'ils doivent tout à fait est ce le
couple qui a fondé cette association qui
sera présent à versailles l'objectif
parce qu'ensuite ils se baladeront un
petit peu un ils vont se brûler un
ensemble de la france en îles font tous
les ans il faut une tournée pour alerter
l'opinion et puis susciter des
parrainages
parce qu'il est là l'enjeu ans c'est
aussi ça c'est leur présence est là pour
faire venir des gens pour assister
écouter leurs témoignages voir ces
images difficile exercice
il ya très sensibilisé parce que un peu
d'argent peut effectivement faire
beaucoup pour ses enfants puisque 36
euros par mois permettent de faire vivre
un enfant 45 permettent de le scolariser
et 80 permettent de leur envoyer en
formation professionnelle donc si vous
voulez plus on est nombreux à se
mobiliser et plus l'association peu de
vrai et c'est d'ailleurs assez touchants
de les voir pendant leur tournée
le soir quand il ya des annonces de
parrainage ils envoient l'information à
phnom penh pour que déjà les services
sociaux qui identifie les enfants dans
le besoin
sache que ils pourront l'année prochaine
accueillir trois cinq dix enfants de
plus en tant qu'ils en ont bien besoin
il reste encore effectivement beaucoup à
faire on vous incite donc à vous rendre
à versailles lundi pour découvrir ce
documentaire rencontrer ce couple
étonnant qui a fondé cette association
et puis parler de l'engagement de ps
pourra sourire d'enfant
merci à vous